[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
are you going to say hello walter again
welcome walter thank you
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us again together
lord it's so wonderful to study your
word and everything that you gave us but
we need the holy spirit's enlightenment
and that we ask now in jesus name amen
amen
now martin we spoke about grace
about grace abounding last time
and we need to show
the other side of the story
but it has to be in harmony with the
first part of the story or else you have
half a story correct correct
and this has caused much perplexity in
the course of history
so we've titled this one show me your
faith
and of course it comes from
james where he talks about show me my
faith without thy works
that i may sow thee my faith by my works
so this is james 2 verse 18 yea a man
may say
thou hast faith and i have works
show me thy faith without thy works and
i will show thee my faith by my works
this basically sums up the battle
between protestantism and catholicism
that's it
and the internal battle that many
experience
along these same lines
and of course if you if you put the
emphasis on either side of the story
then you're either
a perfectionist
or you're a liberalist right so which
one are you martin no i would love to be
both both okay
so the issue around which the great
controversy revolves is jesus christ
that we saw in grace abounding yes
so the difference between bible faith
and all other religions of the world is
the centrality of christ
and the meaning of faith
but no matter which way you look at it
christ is the stumbling block right yes
and
if we just look at ecumenism
he has to be taken out of the equation
otherwise they cannot be any and you
cannot preach doctrine because then you
have stumble blocks
no matter what you say you can have a
stumbling block
so what are the issues his deity
well just read the quran
and you'll see how fiery it is against
any claim that jesus
is deity
jesus says the
creator major problem right
redeemer
no we want to redeem ourselves by our
works
his atonement
i mean it's just amazing to me that so
few people within catholicism know that
catholicism denies the atonement yes
a lot of people in catholicism
actually believe themselves in the
atonement yes but they don't even know
that their own church doesn't teach
the atonement correct now that that even
to me was a tremendous shock and i came
through catholicism
they don't believe in the atonement in
fact they're vehemently opposed to it
and then justification
the central pillar of protestantism
is condemned
in the council of trent
sanctification
glorification i mean these are all
issues that can keep you occupied
at infinitum
so all of these actually are irreducible
they are a package
if you take one out yes you lose them
all right
if you lose the deity of christ or his
redemption or the atonement or
justification or sanctification or
glorification which are all in christ
you've lost them all
that's it so what's the point
of accepting him as the creator
but you
deny that he is the one that sanctifies
you and will eventually glorify you yes
big problem no can that work so if you
believe by faith that christ justifies
imputed righteousness and that christ
sanctifies imparted righteousness
then show me your faith by your works
if you don't have any fruits
then you are saying that you're not
justified
nor are you sanctified
so how do i judge
by the fruits
and what are the fruits
well your actions according to the law
you see
people say that god is love
and they preach a gospel of love yes
god is love
now
what is love
that is the crux
what is the definition of love exactly
is it just this little fluffy thing what
what is love and what are the criteria
that govern love
love without law
cannot be love
because love
wants to
place the other one first right yes
and love
is unselfish
so i must ask myself
what are
the attributes of god
that i have to know
and
what must i do in order to please god
well he tells me what his attributes are
he gives me his law
and then love compels me to come into
harmony with that law
because if i'm not in harmony with that
law
then i am a thief and a liar
and the truth is not in you and the
truth is not in me because
you know you have to love god
and the love of god
is
demonstrated in his law
so that's love to god and love to your
neighbor so love without law
is a lollipop yeah means nothing nothing
so let's just look at this isaiah
chapter 45 25 in the lord shall all the
seed of israel be justified and shall
glory
so let us not forget that
everything is in christ
matthew 12 37 for by thy words thou
shalt be justified
and by thy words thou shalt be condemned
whoops
all right so what comes out here
is an indication of what is happening in
there right
acts 13 39 and by him all that believe
are justified from all things
from which ye could not be justified by
the law of moses
just a reminder
that justification is a gift and it
comes from christ yes it cannot be
earned no
so let's contrast these two texts
romans 2 13 for not the hearer of the
law
or just before god but the doers of the
law shall be justified
this sounds like works right yes
romans 3 28 therefore we conclude that a
man is justified by faith without the
deeds of the law
that sounds like the opposite right
so are these two in opposition to each
other
no you have to find the harmony
there must be harmony between the two
right
so both are true correct
and again
the answer is both can only be true in
christ yes
so this is where we often get stuck
because we read one
but we don't put it in juxtaposition
so now if you add james into the wicks
then you can get very confused
[Laughter]
it's not surprising that martin luther
was confused
so james chapter 2 verse 21 to 24 was
not abram our father justified by works
when he had offered isaac his son upon
the altar sees thou how faith wrought
with his works
and by works was faith made perfect
and the scripture was fulfilled which
says abraham believed god and it was
imputed unto him for righteousness
and he was called the friend of god you
see then how that by works a man is
justified and not by faith only
this seems to be the exact opposite of
what paul said
so
did they come to
to blows did they have fisticuffs
so you add the god of the old testament
the god of the new testament but if you
take james which is in the new testament
it negates all of that there's a
difference between the two
yes and and you have paul and you have
james both in the new testament both in
the new testament
and looking it looks as if they're
talking contrary to each other no but
they're not they can't they are actually
enhancing one another
so how do you know that abraham had
faith
because he acted upon it yes you could
see it yes you could see it
so the fact that he
demonstrated his faith
showed that he
had faith
so this is basically what james is
saying right correct
so if there is no fruit of the faith how
do you know that you've been justified
there must be a change if abraham
did not have faith would he still have
been
willing to sacrifice isaac
no he would not but he demonstrated his
faith by being willing
and some people you know say that there
was a cruel request of god
but basically what he was doing he was
in abraham giving a mini enactment of
the plan of salvation
and in the same
era when abram
had to do this
there were actually people offering
children to gods
absolutely
so that's what that can also have been a
struggle for abraham
i can imagine it was a struggle
and he also had to do it in the exact
same location
where the crucifixion eventually took
place
it's a really an amazing story
so a good tree needs regular food and
water in order to produce good fruit
so we need regular living water and the
solid food of the word in order to
produce good fruit right
but you can read your bible until you're
blue in the face it doesn't mean that
you will change yeah
so who provides the water and the food
god okay we feed
and water the tree but the roots of the
tree still have to absorb it in order to
benefit
yeah you can you have a freedom of
choice you can reject it exactly
so who provides us with the spiritual
food and drink that we need in order to
grow spiritually and to produce good
fruit the answer obviously is god god
so god provides it but we must still
absorb it in order to benefit
now what evidence do we have that you
absorbed it
how do we know that we have absorbed it
and assimilated it
by the spiritual growth and the good
fruit that the tree produces yes so
there's no fruit on the tree
it didn't work right didn't work
you bypassed it so these are issues that
we need to
think about so what kind of faith do we
need
galatians 2 16 says knowing that a man
is not justified by the works of the law
but by the faith of jesus christ
that puts it a step up
above the faith of abraham right yes
even we have believed in jesus christ
that we might be justified by the faith
of christ so we've highlighted those
those
little words in and of
and they make a huge difference
now if you take new translations that's
lost
correct it's totally different to have
the faith in jesus than the faith of
jesus yes because you've had the faith
in jesus
then you're on a human level yes if you
have the faith of jesus you have to
strive to that the whole time because
it's easily it's a much higher level all
of these nuances are totally
lost
in the new translations
knowing that a man is not justified by
the works of the law but by the faith of
jesus christ that's a very high bar
even we have believed
in jesus that's what i'm capable of
christ that we might be justified by the
faith
of christ
and not by the works of the law for by
the works of the law shall no flesh be
justified the bar is so high
i cannot attain to it in my human
capacity only in my sphere can i attain
to it
now what about glorification
as to growth and ripening what does the
plant need it needs the early and the
latter rain right
so everybody in a conversion goes
through an early rain experience and a
latter rain experience
but the latter rain
leads to ripening of the fruit
the early reign leads to the capacity to
produce the fruit
so romans 8 30 says moreover whom he did
predestinate and that's everyone has
that choice whomsoever
then he also called and whom he called
them he also justified and whom he
justified them he also glorified again
you have a progression
now how serious is this matter
pretty serious right god means what he
says yeah so if you take the story of
nadab and abayu
leviticus 10 1-3 and nadab and abayu the
sons of aaron took either of them his
sensor
and put fire there in and put incense
there on and offered strange fire
before the lord
the fire had to be kindled from the
flame which the lord had kindled
but they took their own fire
which he commanded them not and they
went out fire from the lord and devoured
them and they died before the lord then
moses said unto aaron
this is it that the lord spake saying i
will be sanctified in them that come
nigh me
and before all the people i will be
glorified and aaron held his peace
you see they
had decided to do it their way
and it was forbidden to pray for priests
to
drink wine or strong drink
and they
decided that they would do it so they
came half inebriated
and did their own thing
and the result was seeing that this was
an object lesson
that god had to make it very plain
that they're dealing with a high and
holy god correct there has to be
reverence yes
so this
what does this tell you martin about
this
buddy buddy
attitude of people
regarding god
no and they refer to him as the man
upstairs or
the buddy or your thirst your pal i mean
we're dealing with god aren't we yes you
have to harmonize that as well he's a
friend
but he's not
he's still god correct
there's a certain amount of respect
that's that is due like there should be
between a child and a parent yes
isaiah 49 3 and said unto me thou art my
servant of israel in whom i will be
glorified in other words what must be
your attitude
when you are dealing with the things of
god you can't
approach it in a flippant
manner
isaiah 55 5 behold thou shalt call a
nation that thou knowest not
and nations that knew not thee shall run
unto thee because of the lord thy god
and for the holy one of israel for he
has glorified thee
why would people run
to you to find out what you are all
about
if there is no difference between you
and the others
then you have to be peculiar
you have to be a peculiar people you
have to be different different well
isaiah 60 verse 21 thy people also shall
be all righteous they shall inherit the
land forever the branch of my planting
the work of my hands that i might be
glorified
when you become like the nations around
you you're not glorifying god
there must be a difference there must be
fruit
it also come the
corinthians
whether you eat or drink or whatever you
do do it the glory of god correct
so
you know he is the resurrection and the
life so let's look at this little story
about jesus raising a widow's son
luke chapter 7 11-13 and it came to pass
the day after
that he went into a city called nain
and many of his disciples went with him
and much people
now when he came nigh to the gate of the
city behold there was a dead man carried
out
the only son of his mother and she was a
widow
and much people of the city was with him
when the lord saw her he had compassion
on her and said unto her
weep not
now there's more to the story than you
can literally see there
because
there was this widow
and she only had
one son
so that was our whole livelihood
because if you were alone you were
destitute right
and he came and touched the buyer
and they that bare him stood still and
he said young man
i say unto thee arise
and he that was dead sat up and began to
speak
and he delivered him to his mother and
there came
fear on all
now
this fear were they afraid
or were they over or yes overalled
shocked actually
they were stunned stunned yes okay
and they glorified god yes
so what did they do they sang his
praises
saying that a great prophet is arisen
amongst us
and that god has visited these people
and this rumor of him went forth
throughout judea and throughout all the
region round about
so in other words when you come into
contact with god who has the power to
resurrect even the dead
and if you have a spiritual application
the spiritually dead can also be erected
right
so
what about lazarus
did he glorify god because of his
resurrection
absolutely right
did his sisters glorify god because of
his resurrection
did it make him puffed up or did it make
him humble humble
now did everybody glorify god because of
lazarus's resurrection no not at all
jesus even tell the pharisees even if
somebody is raised from the dead he
would not believe it and exactly that's
what they didn't believe and they wanted
to murder him exactly that's amazing
right so you'll always have two sides
you'll have the believers and you'll
have the deniers
so what about the woman with the
disabling spirit if you go to luke
chapter 13 we read and he was teaching
in one of the synagogues on the sabbath
and behold there was a woman which had a
spirit of infirmity 18 years and was
bowed together
and could in no wise lift up herself
and when jesus saw i called her to him
and said unto her woman
thou art loosed from thine infirmity
and he laid his hands on her and
immediately she was made straight
and glorified god they have the same
thing
now woman is also a symbol of the church
and many of us
we need to be made straight because all
of us are crooked
so she glorified god
in other words when you are made
straight
spiritually speaking
you must glorify god
in other words you give him the honor
right
you give him the respect
and how does that pan out in your daily
life
your fruits has to show it
and the ruler of the synagogue answered
with indignation
you'll always have that right
because that jesus had healed on the
sabbath day and said unto the people
there are six days in which men ought to
work
in them therefore come and be healed and
not on the sabbath day
so
you know
if you have a legalistic disposition
yes
and you exclude the element of grace
and compassion
and kindness
and concern
then you don't have the gospel no and
then you totally misunderstand what
the sabbath is about and that is why
jesus cursed that fig tree
it had presumptuous leaves but no fruit
yeah
and it should have had fruit because
figs produce fruits before they produce
their leaves
or let's look at the one that was healed
from of leprosy
only one in 10 came back
luke chapter 17 verse 15 and one of them
when he saw that he was healed came back
and with a loud voice glorified god
which one had fruit
only one
this one what happened to the other nine
they were fig trees
they were victories
john 15 verse 8 erin is my father
glorified that you bear much fruit so
shall ye be my disciples so if there's
no fruit
then you are demonstrating that you are
a user
yes
so there were nine users
[Music]
but only one who glorified god and jesus
said in john 17 4 i have glorified thee
on earth i have finished the work which
thou gaveth me to do
so each one of us has a work to do
he says i have kept my father's
commandments
so he wants us to keep his commandments
that's this other side of the story and
just for clarity there's no difference
between jesus's commandments and god and
his father's commandments
so
when jesus glorified
god on earth
then it must be possible for us to
glorify it because it says so in those
previous texts
so how did he glorify his father would
be the next question right
we need to study
jesus
so we go to hebrews chapter 10 and it
says for it is not possible
that the blood of bulls and of goats
should take away sins wherefore when he
cometh into the world he says sacrifice
and offering thou wouldest not
but the body has thou prepared me
in burnt offerings and sacrifices for
sin thou hast had no pleasure
then said i
lo i come in the volume of the book it
is written of me to do thy will
o god
so how do you glorify god to do his will
okay so a ritual performance of
sacrifices and motions does that do it
no
going to church regularly and showing
that you're in the church and that you
have the right posture does that do it
if it doesn't come from
a conviction
doesn't mean anything nothing how many
people go to church because
it is what society does
so sacrifice on offering and burnt
offering and offering for sin thou which
not neither had its pleasure therein
which are offered by the law
then said i lo i come to do thy will o
god he taketh away the first
that he may establish the second
by the which we are sanctified through
the offering of the body of jesus christ
once for all
so salvation is a matter of the heart
and it is always displayed in obedience
to the will of god
and this taketh away the first and
establish the second is that the
sacrificial
the system official system which pointed
to the great reality
but the motion is not satisfied the
reality is satisfying
so it's interesting when you read those
words lo i come
they are used as an imperative
in other words to put power behind the
verse right
and it occurs five times in the bible
and we read them in exodus 19 9 and the
lord said unto moses lo i come unto thee
in a thick cloud
that the people may hear when i speak
with thee and believe thee forever and
moses told the words
of the people unto the lord so here you
have this display of his power
or psalms 14 verse 7 then said i lo i
come and the volume of the book it is
written of me that's what hebrews just
quoted or zechariah sing and rejoice o
daughter of zion for lo i come and i
will dwell in the midst of thee says the
lord
that's a pronouncement that's like a
taking a
trumpet and pronouncing that god is
going to become
part and parcel of humanity that's
amazing
then said i says hebrew lo i come we've
just read it to do the will of god
and lo i come to do thy will oh god he
taketh away the first so those are the
five times that we have these words lo i
come
and each time they are associated with
the law
the first one is sinai
right yes
so the question i have is do we have a
similar work in the time that we are
living now let us look at the experience
of paul as a persecutor of god's people
when he was transformed by the grace of
god
so
he was a persecutor he was doing one
thing
and then he changed and did something
else right yeah the opposite of what it
is directly opposite yeah okay
galatians 1 chapter 21 to 24. afterwards
i came into the region of syria and
selezia and was unknown by faith unto
the churches of judea
which were in christ
but they had heard only that he which
persecuted us in the times past now
preached the faith
which once he destroyed
and they glorified god in me
what does that mean
they were happy
that this guy has changed his way yes
and they glorified god for now some
didn't believe it they didn't yet
glorify god but when they
saw the reality yeah
then they glorified god so when ananias
was told by the by the lord that he had
to go to paul
he was you know something's wrong here
he wasn't happy at all
yeah and he didn't glorify god not that
that not there no but later on
absolutely then he glorified god okay so
what it changed
there was fruit
of repentance
and
paul was no longer the same person he
was a different person in fact he was
the opposite of what he was before
so how did they glorify it obviously
they saw the transformation and they
rejoiced and the enemy became a dear
friend that's all
and that's how it must be with us right
2 thessalonians 1 verse 10 and when he
shall come to be glorified in his saints
and to be admired in all them that
believe because our testimony among you
was believed in that day
so how's god glorified in his saints
and people must see this
and they must react accordingly
or ii thessalonians 3 1 finally brethren
pray for us
that the word of the lord may have free
course and be glorified even as it is
with you
so this glorification
is a joy yes
and a praise
that rises to the throne of god
because of a change that has taken place
somebody is healed
somebody is raised from the dead
somebody has experienced a
renewed spiritual life from a spiritual
death
and that has to have fruit now
so it is no good that people come into
our churches and they see no difference
between us and the world would you agree
martin definitely
so what convinced the queen of sheba
solomon was the wisest man that ever
lived
and what an indictment that the wisest
man that ever lived lived as the biggest
fool that ever lived
right yep
they say that all's well that ends well
but don't bank on that rather say all's
well that stays well
at least his conclusion was right when
he said let us hear the conclusion of
the whole matter fear god and keep his
commandments for this is the whole duty
of man
and when that queen of sheba came and
she heard about the wisdom of solomon
is that what convinced her
no
when she saw the temple exactly
when she saw the seating arrangement
of his servants even
i mean what king would have his servants
sit next to him
unbelievable you don't do that right
they must be when she saw
their attire the way in which they were
dressed
when she saw the food on his table
that's an interesting
then
she had no spirit to argue anymore
and every single question that she asked
him he was able to answer from scripture
right yes
don't you have a story also
about somebody that came to visit you to
come and see if you actually
practice what you preach
yes there was a man
and he came to see
whether this was really true whether we
really did eat differently
than other people
and he became an evangelist eventually
so it is very important
that we actually
practice what we preach we cannot have a
health message
and not live it
lip service
doesn't cut it right
so when people come to our churches
and they see
coffee and
animal products and they see no
difference whatsoever
what example does that give to the
people
paul writes in second corinthians
examine yourselves whether you be in the
faith
prove your own selves
it's it's a good thing to sit down and
say
you know have a little bit of
introspection
am i doing this right
and if you lack wisdom what do you do
you go to the word you go to the word
and you say give me wisdom
now you're not your own selves how that
jesus christ is in you except you be
reprobates
in other words martin if you're a
reprobate he's not in you
isn't that what he's saying yep
but i trust that you shall know that we
are not reprobates
now i pray to god that you do no evil
not that we should appear approved
but ye should do that which is honest
though we be as reprobates
for we can do nothing against the truth
but for the truth that's one of my
favorite statements
you can do nothing against the truth
you can shout and scream about it you
can publish articles against it and you
only make it prominent yes in fact some
of the best advertisements we've ever
had
in our little ministry
is when people write
vociferously against it
exactly they just
increase the publicity the publicity
marvelous marvelous you can do nothing
against it
and wesley writes regarding verse 5
prove yourself
whether you are such as can or such as
cannot bear the test this is the proper
meaning of the word which we translate
reprobates know ye not yourselves that
jesus christ is in you all christian
believers know this
by the witness and by the fruit of his
spirit
some translate the words jesus christ is
among you that is in the church of
corinth and understand them of the
miraculous gifts and the power of christ
which attended the centuries of the
apostles
in other words what he is saying is
basically only by the fruit of what you
are doing can you see whether you are in
christ or whether you are not they
sometimes write in this complicated way
so revelation 14 verse 7 says saying
with a loud voice fear god and give
glory to him
for the hour of his judgment is come
and worship him that made the heavens
the earth the sea and the fountains of
waters
fear god have respect for god after all
he's the creator
of heaven and earth
and give glory to him
you didn't do it nope
you didn't create it
you didn't recreate it
you didn't lift it up when it fell yes
and you didn't humiliate yourself
from the position of deity to the
position of humanity to come and do it
yeah
so give glory to god
why the hour of his judgment has come
judgment has a standard which is the law
by contrast the world glorifies itself
and does not glory in
christ the great of babylon sets
the example
she speaks lofty words and claims the
moral high ground but she will be
brought low because she sets our own
standard
that's not giving glory to god that's
giving glory to yourself self yes right
so how do you determine whether somebody
glorifies god or whether he glorifies
himself
well he's fruit and must
be in harmony with the bible exactly so
if he's not in harmony with the bible
then he's glorifying himself
revelation 18 7 how much he has
glorified herself
and lived deliciously so much torment
and sorrow give her for she says in her
heart i sit as a queen and am not a
widow and shall see no sorrow
so martin there are two systems in the
world
that are competing
for your attention
and the one that you choose will
determine
your eternal existence or not right
so it's actually a question of salvation
in luke chapter 7 verse 50 says to the
woman thy faith has saved thee go in
peace
in 18 42 and jesus said unto him receive
thy sight thy faith has saved thee
ephesians 2 verse 8 for by grace you are
saved through faith and that not of
yourselves it is the gift of god so even
the faith that you have
is a gift yes and
the question that you asked earlier as
well how do you um then determine if
it's
if it's according to the bible
the the fruits
and as
if god gets the glory out of it
because as soon as it is
glorifying self
it's not in harmony with the bible
imagine the bible says
there is no way
other than through christ whereby you
can be saved right
and you teach people that they can go to
a priest
for forgiveness of sins
or you teach people that they can go to
a dead person
yeah to receive
mediation
or you teach that
you go to
a
earthly prelate
in order to get relief from damnation on
the other side
what are you doing
glorifying self
definitely every single step of the way
what if somebody says
that all power in heaven has been given
unto us
are they also doing that yes but what
power are they using then they're using
the power of christ so who must be
glorified christ exactly
if you turn that round and you apply it
to self then you are glorifying self
exactly
so when he says that thy faith has saved
thee
then he's referring to a faith that
works
and not to have faith
that has nothing to do
with the word of god
samadhin if you are saved by faith
then that faith must be applied in some
way right
so how is it applied
again through grace
in case you think that you are doing
something great yeah yeah
so if we read acts 15 verse 11 but we
believe that through the grace of the
lord jesus christ we shall be saved
your faith has saved you
that's what he said to the woman right
through the grace of the lord jesus
christ
we shall be saved
so the faith has to be applied
through grace
ephesians 2 5 even when we were dead in
sins has quickened us together with
christ by grace you are saved
or verse 8 for by grace you are saved
through faith and that not of yourselves
it is the gift of god
or timothy ii timothy 1 9 who has saved
us and has called us with his holy
calling not according to our works but
according to his own purpose and grace
which was given us in christ jesus
before the world began before we were
even there
so
even though there must be works
you cannot exclude faith and grace no
you cannot like you said in the
beginning you cannot have the one side
and not the other they have to be
together so there is beautiful harmony
even if people don't want to see it
right
that's why romans 3 verse 27 puts it
succinctly and says where is boasting
then
it is excluded by what law by works
no but by the law of faith
so that gets rid of any form of legalism
you cannot even boast in the fact that
you are doing things right
because the fact that you are doing
things right is purely by grace yes
that is perfectly put and if you do not
do it then you are giving evidence that
you have not received grace yes
because of your own stubbornness yes not
because of any fault
yeah not because you have grace you
cannot you don't have to do it if you're
not doing it you're showing that you
don't have any grace exactly so he
supplies it to you exactly
and
the question is are you going to take it
or not and i like how they
paul puts it the law of faith
that's right yeah by what law
works no but by the law of faith
so romans 9 32 wherefore
because they sought it not by faith but
as it were by the works of the law for
they stumbled at that stumbling stone
and today we have the same problem
or galatians 2 16 knowing that a man is
not justified by the works of the law
but by the faith of jesus christ even we
have believed in jesus christ we've had
this verse before
so it's not by the works of the law for
by the works of the law shall no flesh
be justified
galatians 3 verse 2 this only would i
learn of you received ye the spirit by
the works of the law by the hearing of
faith
rhetorical question
or verse 5 and chapter 3 he therefore
that ministers to you the spirit and
worketh miracles amongst you does he it
by the works of the law by the hearing
of faith
so everything comes back to this point
that it is by grace that you are saved
but if you do not have the works
then you haven't accepted the grace
so if we go to the spirit of prophecy we
read that the righteousness by which we
are justified is imputed
the righteousness by which we are
sanctified is imparted
the first is our title to heaven and the
second is our fitness for heaven
but both come from an extraneous source
outside of yours it's an alien
righteousness
well christ object lessons page 65 the
germination of the seed represents the
beginning of spiritual life
and the development of the plant is a
beautiful figure of christian growth as
in nature so in grace
there can be no life without growth the
plant must either grow or die
as its growth is silent and
imperceptible
but continuous so is the development of
christian life
at every stage of development our life
may be perfect
yet if god's purpose for us is fulfilled
there will be continual advancement
sanctification is the work of a lifetime
so this is not an instant thing
so i cannot expect
a newborn
to walk by himself perfectly
but when those first little steps are
taken don't the parents rejoice
yes but aren't those steps pathetic
in the broader picture yes keep falling
down right
but you're rejoicing because
at that moment those steps are perfect
in that sphere
what will be the attitude of those who
are daily advancing towards perfection
quoting job if i justify myself my own
mouth shall condemn me
but if i say i am perfect
it shall also prove me perverse
though i were perfect yet would i
not know my soul i would despise my life
that's a beautiful summary
that's what we
discussed in the previous talk on grace
every single one of those reformers
knew that they were in need of grace
correct
so true holiness and humility are
inseparable the nearer the soul comes to
god the more completely it is humbled
and subdued the more closely and
continuously we behold our savior
the less shall we see to approve in
ourselves so there's a key martin
people that are constantly boasting
about what they have achieved in terms
of their
perfection
are actually in a very precarious place
hebrews 6 1 therefore leaving the
principles of the doctrine of christ let
us go on unto perfection not laying
again the foundation of repentance from
dead works and of faith towards god
so in other words there is this request
you must grow
you must keep on growing
when we spoke about this in an earlier
episode
we mentioned the thief on the cross
correct
so his lifetime
of sanctification
was just very short correct but it was
perfect but it was perfect and it was
through
god's grace absolutely again yes
so john chapter 2 verse 14 what does it
profit my brethren though man say as
faith and have not works
can faith
save him
well you are saved by faith so obviously
faith can save you but if you don't have
works then it shows that you didn't
really have faith correct
that's what he's saying
even so faith if it has not worked is
dead being alone
yes you have to have the works of faith
he has to have the works otherwise
you're a dead plant yeah if you have
works but it's not of faith
it's coming from that your faith
it's also dead correct
well verse 18 a man say those faith and
i have worked showed me thy faith by
their works and i will show thee my
faith by my works it's actually a very
clever
clever verse
it has caused much perplexity
but wilt i now know ovine man that faith
without works is dead see is thou how
faith wrought with his works and by
works was faith made perfect
so when we read it now in this context
then it makes perfect sense right
you see then how that by works a man is
justified and not by faith only
if you take that work that verse by
itself
then you can end up with catholicism
and you can justify an anathema yes if
you take that one just by yourself then
actually you can say this
this verse is
contradictory to the other verses
contradicts paul when he says by faith
you are justified and not by works
but in actual fact if you read the
justification in the right context that
the proof of the justification lies in
the fruits
then it makes perfect sense
or verse 26 for as the body without the
spirit is dead so faith without works is
dead also
makes perfect sense
now if you go to the book of revelation
and then we are talking about
eschatology and the end of time
where jesus says i know thy works and
where thou dwellest even where satan sit
is
and they hold holdest fast my name and
has not denied my faith isn't that
interesting
my faith
even in those days when antipas was my
faithful martyr who was slain amongst
you where satan dwelleth
he was talking about
pergamon
where you had the altar of zias
and where
the priesthood of babylon had its seat
so basically we are living
where satan has his seat today as well
right yes
and if we want to survive then we must
have the faith of jesus my faith
my faith and you can live in a world
that denies christ
and that is ready to martyr
those that believe in him
and you can stand firm if you have this
faith
so in verse 19 he says i know thy works
and charity and service and faith and
thy patience and thy works and the last
to be more than the first
so god is not against works
he is four works and he has a book of
remembrance and he writes them down
and those works are not because of your
strength but because of his strength
so we mustn't forget how
works
work together with faith because
justified by faith
is
part of that equation here
galatians 2 15 to 18 we who are jews by
nature that's another one where
uh you know this argument that we had in
previous talks is one of those examples
where he refers to christians
as jews yes
so he's actually spiritualizing the word
jew correct he's talking to the
galatians he's talking
not to those in jerusalem
and he's called them jews by nature
and not sinners of the gentiles knowing
that a man is not justified by the works
of the law but by the faith of jesus
christ
even we have believed in jesus christ
we've had this verse before
but just for clarity that we might be
justified by the faith
of christ and not by the works of the
law
then he says but
if we seek to be justified by christ we
ourselves are found sinners therefore is
christ the minister of sin god forbid
for if i build again the things which
are destroyed i make myself a
transgressor
what's he saying
if i go back to my old ways
there must be a change
so
faith and works must go together correct
there must be a change this is the
persecutor speaking
who has become the non-persecutor
if we go to verse 19
and you ask ourselves then what was
destroyed must be the old man of sin
right
for i through the law
and dead to the law that i might live
unto god.
i am crucified with christ now when he's
talking about the law he's talking about
the torah and he's talking about the
rituals
and
wasn't that a great fear of the jews
that jesus was coming to
destroy their economy basically yeah
that was their greatest fear right
didn't the high priest say it is better
that one man die for the sake of the
people
than that the people should die for the
sake of one man
so let's get rid of him because he's
going to destroy
our way of life yes he's going to get
rid
of our religious system as we knew it
and there's the crux of the matter isn't
it interesting that also
in the end
that rock that comes loose
not by any human hand will destroy all
religious and all kingdoms and political
systems so that which they were afraid
of that it would be destroyed will
eventually be destroyed anyway exactly
and
the remnant that remained of those jews
they became the christians
and very soon
this same debate took place within
christendom as well
and we've now come to the culmination to
the point in history where there will be
a climax
so we better be crucified in christ
nevertheless i live not i
but christ lives in me and the life
which i now live in the flesh i live by
the faith of the son of god who loved me
and gave himself for me
i do not frustrate the grace of god
for if righteousness came by the law
then christ is dead in vain
so
he doesn't frustrate the grace of god
doesn't deny the grace of god
but he is a transformed person
the old man is gone
different person
now martin here's a quote from the
ministry of healing
and it is very revealing because it says
not because we first love him did christ
love us
but while we were yet sinners he died
for us
he does not treat us according to our
desert although our sins have merited
condemnation he does not condemn us
what do we call that
grace christ
year after year he has borne with our
weakness and ignorance with our
ingratitude and waywitness
notwithstanding our wonderings our
hardness of heart our neglect of his
holy word his hand is stretched out
still
grace is an attribute of god
exercised towards undeserving human
beings
we did not seek for it
but it was sent in search of us
god rejoices to bestow his grace upon us
not because we are worthy but because we
are so utterly unworthy
our only claim to his mercy
is our great need
the lord god through jesus christ holds
out his hand all the day long in
invitation to the sinful and fallen
he will receive all
he welcomes all
it is his glory to pardon the chief of
sinners
that's an amazing statement isn't it
definitely he gets glorified
when a sinner
changes correct his way he will take the
prey from the mighty he will deliver the
captive he will pluck the brand from the
burning he will lower the golden chain
of his mercy to the lowest depth of
human wretchedness and lift up the
debased soul contaminated with sin
you try and tell me that that is not
inspired
and it does away with all
self-glorification
it's gone
and yet you must have works yes
the will must be placed on the side of
god's will
you are not able of yourself to bring
your purposes and desires and
inclination into submission to the will
of god
but if you are willing to be made
willing
god will accomplish the work for you so
martin your works
are they
works of self or are they by grace
grace
grace yes there's nothing
in you so is
james in disharmony with grace no
when it is in the heart to obey god when
efforts are put forth to this end jesus
accepts this disposition and effort as
man's best service
and he makes up for the deficiency with
his own divine merit
that's
what it's all about
it's again it gives you hope correct
this is the the question of in your
sphere
christ looks at the spirit and when he
sees us carrying our burdens with faith
he's perfect holiness atones for our
shortcomings
when we do our best
he becomes our righteousness
faith
together with works
the father beholds not your faulty
character but he sees you as clothed in
my perfection says god
the desire of ages page 357
so
this question of faith and works
if we don't understand it from the basis
of grace
then we have lost it yeah
so let's put it beyond a question of
doubt manuscripts 5 1885 only those far
from christ claim sinlessness
why is it that so many claim to be holy
and sinless
it is because they are so far from
christ i have never dared to claim any
such thing from the time that i was 14
years old
if i knew what the will of god was i was
willing to do it you have never heard me
say i am sinless
those that get sight of the loveliness
and exalted character of jesus christ
who was holy and lifted up in his train
fills the temple will never say it
yet we are to meet with those that will
say such things more
and more that's quite
sad i love this statement
nothing is apparently more helpless
yet really more invincible than the
souls that feels its nothingness and
relies wholly on the merits of the
savior
by prayer by the study of his word by
faith in his abiding presence
the weakest of human beings may live in
contact with the living christ
and he will hold them by a hand that
will never let go
it's one of the most beautiful
statements in the whole of the spirit of
prophecy
i love how she says
apparently more helpless
because for the beholder of that person
he looks helpless
but yet really more invincible because
his total reliance is on god exactly and
the weakest of signs
is the strongest of saints if he has
faith
so these precious words every soul that
abides in christ may make his own and
then she quotes a number of verses
and i thought it would be good to use
this particular quote from ministry of
healing because
it it quotes those particular verses how
do you how do you deal with the issue
of faith and works
i will look unto the lord i will wait
for the god of my salvation my god will
hear me
rejoice not against me o my enemy when i
fall i shall arise when i sit in
darkness the lord shall be a light unto
me there's a promise that's a promise in
my in my car
so you know people are so watchful is
this person doing exactly what he should
be doing
and being so judgmental
and then she quotes micah 7 19.
he will again have compassion on us he
will blot out our iniquities yea thou
will cast all our sins into the depth of
the sea
and god has promised i will make a man
more precious than find gold even a man
than the golden wedge of fear so martin
rather than
than struggling in your own strength
if you leave out the element of
faith
and grace
you will never attain to this peace of
mind
she quotes psalms 68 13 which says
though you have lain amongst the pots
yet shall ye be as the wings of a dove
covered with silver
and have feathers with yellow gold in
other words if you've been lying there
amongst the feeding troughs of the
animals
so those whom christ have forgiven most
will love him most
these are they who in the final day will
stand nearest to his throne
they shall see his face and his name
shall be in their foreheads
so martin
if you want to rely on your works
and forget where you come from
then you are in serious trouble
so when faith and works go together
they will always remember where we came
from
and that we are standing where we stand
by the grace of christ yes alone
revelation 22 14 says blessed are they
that do his commandments so james is not
wrong
that they may have the right to the tree
of life and may enter in through the
gates into the city
now the new translations change that of
course to wash their robes but they
don't even add in the blood of the lamb
no means nothing and it's such a small
change
from the original greek
so faith and works
and the grace of christ
are in absolute harmony with each other
justification
is a work of god
sanctification is an imparted
righteousness
but you only know that you have received
them
if you have fruits thereof
so show me your faith
by your works
and then i can know that you have really
appropriated
the righteousness of christ amen
may god give us wisdom
not to become confused
when it comes to the issues
of faith
and works shall we pray thank you
heavenly father
thank you for the book of james
and thank you for the book of romans
and thank you lord that they are in
perfect harmony with each other
and i pray lord
that we will ever
rely on the faith of jesus
to bring us faithfully through to the
sea of glass
i pray this in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here
thank you